I am probably the most optimistic person
in terms of like how good this of a
business podcasting can be and I started
talking crazy and then I have some
friends uh
that have built giant businesses on the
back of podcasts I was at dinner with
them last week and they literally pulled
me to the side and they're like shut the
[__] stop telling people all this [__]
[Music]
all right everyone today's podcast is
special the guy's name is David senra
he's got a podcast called Founders I've
listened to dozens and dozens and dozens
of episodes he basically breaks down
different biographies that he read about
business people artists whatever anyone
who's you know the one percent of the
one percent of their field and on the
Pod today we talked about the difference
between people who are like somewhat
successful and the people who are
absolute killers and what traits they
have and what the commonalities so it's
super fascinating to hear from someone
who's read literally three or four
hundred biographies and studies this for
a living He talks about the
commonalities of these killers whether
that's UFC fighters or billionaires
it's really fascinating I think you're
gonna dig it my favorite part is when we
talk about
um he has this really cool quote from
Joe Rogan describing uh Jon Jones who's
this like amazing UFC fighter and the
difference between like John and the
rest of the people and then somehow
David weaves that in with business
people and he lists out all the business
people who he says are the the one
percent the one percent The Killers of
the killers and he talks about what
traits they have and what you can learn
I think he'll dig it check it out talk
soon
yeah you know it's uh I um I understand
why you'd live in Miami if your family's
there that I that's I don't love like
New York but I'm eventually going to
move there for family so I the family
pers you know supersedes all the other
stuff that that's the only reason we
stay here my wife is Colombian so 70 of
Miami-Dade County is Hispanic all her
family's here like I've been traveling a
lot more for work and like the day I
leave my kids wake up her mom is here
her grandmother's here so like for my
kids perspective like Colombians are
they with South Americans general what
they do is like they're very I like
their multi-generational like housing my
wife grew up in a house connected to her
grandparents house yeah I dig that too
oh that's incredible like I had nothing
like that when I was a kid uh and so I
was like man I really want to live in
California but I'm just gonna stay here
for family and then you know spend my
summers in California what'd you do
before Founders pod uh I've done a [__]
ton of businesses like since I was like
18 years old like I think me and you are
around the same age I might be a few
years older than you
um the business I was working on right
before actually started Founders while I
was doing it was a thing called Robo DB
which is a way to track uh the original
the true origination points of robocalls
through the payment Network
um and it was just like a business that
was like kind of like a clever hack but
I wasn't interested in it the way I was
podcasting so like I was obsessed with
podcasting for for years I remember my
friend Eric he invited me over to his
house one time it's like 2010 he's like
dude you gotta come over and watch this
new podcast do you remember the guy from
uh from Fear Factor I'm like yeah I
watched Fear Factor when I was in like
high school uh and we went to his house
and it's like when Joe Rogan was on like
the white couch and he was on like
Ustream and then he'd have like there'd
be like
things falling down he'd have like you
know the cheesy kind of uh like there'd
be stars or Sparkles and stuff like that
I'm like what is this he's like oh you
can also listen to it on your phone
anytime you want and that just blew my
[__] mind I could not believe that
yeah
were you successful or were you kind of
like a struggling entrepreneur and then
this is like is this your first like
Breakout
this is the first thing that's gonna
make like I'll make a lot more money I
was like making like dentist or doctor
money for like a long time you know like
not struggling but not nearly like you
know what a podcast could could do like
a successful podcast could do how big is
the Pod now in terms of listenership
it [__] crazy right now uh we a few
weeks ago I just cracked uh over a
hundred thousand individual listeners
uh uh per episode no no overall like so
when I signed into like my podcastos it
says like unique listeners last seven
days that's the only I don't I'm not big
on metrics like I don't pay attention at
all I just try to make what I want and
then put it out into the world
um but the one number I want to see grow
is that number because Founders is also
weird good like you could Discover it
now and because the back catalog's ever
going Evergreen like I'll talk to people
they'll Listen to Like the First the
latest few episodes and then they'll go
back and listen to [__] that I did like
six years ago five years ago and it it's
just you right like because you're part
of uh What uh colossal is that it the
Colossus Colossus sorry uh and so they
like sell your ads and they take a cut
and so is it just you and a producer or
what nothing just me
so
um patch I love we were talking a little
bit about this yesterday like um the one
thing I love about podcasting industry
is how uh positive sum everybody is so I
listen to podcast uh Patrick's podcast
for years like uh I was taking no sense
podcast I went back and looked since
like 2019. and last year in May uh my
podcast is a subscription podcast right
you could listen the first 30 minutes if
you want to listen to all of it for the
first six years of in its existence you
had to pay to upgrade right I had no
worse yeah wait oh I don't know you so
you've been doing this for six years
yeah starting 2016. oh wow that's crazy
I to me like you just got on my radar
like a year ago maybe everybody was like
that so Patrick played a big role in
that uh the David and Ben from acquired
they played a big role that was just on
your uh your podcast
um but what happened was
um Patrick just randomly tweeted it out
you know he's got you know this massive
very valuable audience like in size in
terms of size and then average net worth
like he's got one of the most I would
argue he's got the most valuable
business podcast audience of the world
right if you found if you keep if you uh
like the fact the the average net worth
of his audience's stream and uh he just
randomly tweeted out like last May hey
um I never find new podcasts to listen
to I think David Center's Founders
podcast is excellent you should listen
and I was like what the [__] I know you
dude like I watch listen to your podcast
like this is crazy and so I had become
friends with this guy named Sam Hankey
Sam hinky's the former general manager
of this uh Philadelphia 76ers now he's
an investor in Silicon Valley and I knew
he knew Patrick and so I screenshotted
that I was like oh [__] look what your
friend Patrick said and then Sam
immediately put me in a group chat with
Patrick he's like you two should know
each other and so Patrick the first time
we talked we talked for like an hour and
a half we had like the same interest for
addiction podcast addicted history
addicted entrepreneurship all sorts of
stuff and so we were just friends for a
long time and then uh I had several
people Rob Moore being one of them we
should probably talk about uh yeah
uh Rob's been hooking me up constantly
like I'll talk to him and we'll email
back and forth he's always helping me
okay so this is the positive sum nature
of podcasting I'm sorry for those who
don't know Rob Moore Rob Moore and
Andrew huberman are part our partners on
the Pod Rob is the co-founder of the
human lab package so okay
there is this is the interesting thing
one of my favorite quotes I've read
every single thing I could find on Steve
Jobs right and one of my favorite quotes
that really describe uh Steve's one of
his superpowers was that Steve was
gifted at finding Marcus full of
second-rate products and what you what
you guys realized I think as well is
like people people have essentially like
when you're inside podcasting the
perception inside of it is completely
different than what it's outside of it
it's like everybody's like there's too
many of them uh it's too late to get in
and like you need to start a long time
ago and what happens is like everybody
starts podcast quits right and when you
get in there podcasts in general are
full of secondary products Rob Moore and
Andrew huberman uh and I put David and
Ben up here which as well it's like
their first their first class products
and a first class approach to building
their business so Rob
I've never talked to Rob less than two
hours every single time we talk he he
dude look what happened my desk
like what's that oh uh tweet yeah it's
Rob and Andrew have been so relentless
with supporting me for nope like they
have no benefit right they just they
keep like every time Andrew tweets about
me the fact that he was one of his
favorite podcasts is Founders he sends
me of the church just from his tweets
that's crazy right Rob's like hey um we
have this new studio next time you're in
California uh next time you're in
California come out and like I'd love to
give you a tour and our mutual friend
Andrew Wilkinson had invited me to
Victoria so I was like oh I'm actually
flying to Victoria like next week that's
a pain in the ass to get to for Miami
I'll just stop in California for a few
days and see you
Malibu I met up with Rob we talked
podcasting for seven straight hours
that's crazy literally we meet up to
have lunch we stay at the same spot
they're like uh it's dinner now we're
like let's have dinner and then we
stayed there the whole time and then
he's like let's go to the studio they
are
like to me I think uh not only is
huberman's the size of his audience
crazy but if you break down on how they
think about the quality of the product
how they think what's quality of the
business model like there's ideas I got
from Rob that I told Andrew or I told um
Ben and David that they're now using
that's going to wind up making them
millions of dollars like the way they
set up their business their ads
everything they're just [__] first
class to do this are you uh I see that
you're always tweeting out it looks like
a screenshot from Kindle uh how many
books a month are you reading to to pull
this off okay so I think this is um me
and you were talking about the advantage
I think you have at Hampton which is
really [__] special
um and it's an echo of what Bloomberg
used to build his very unique business
like your business is going to produce a
lot of proprietary information it's
extremely valuable to other Founders and
then you can repurpose them do you know
any [__] people have had dinner with
that tell me about the Hampton blog and
you guys just
just launched oh really I think we just
we just we just like I I threw it
together like I think two weeks ago I
heard about some guy doing concrete or
some [__] or yeah yeah or something he
was like searching they told me he was
like searching through like uh like War
Dogs uh yeah yeah like looking for the
look into a database of government
contracts and seeing what he can fulfill
yeah so what I realized is when I text
you that or uh yesterday was I'm doing
similar things so
um
I realized what and it this is the the
magic of you said something that was
really smart where you're like rich
people read a lot and it's very true our
mutual friend Andrew Wilkins had just
tweeted out he's like I wish I could
short entrepreneurs that don't read and
that's what I found as well it's like
not only if the people I study is like
they had they were so good at what they
did
that somebody wrote a book about them
like that's [__] crazy right and then
you read their books and they're
constantly reading biographies studying
great work that came before them and so
the Bloomberg idea was like his business
is fundamentally he's like I want to
sell you like a 27 000 year subscription
or whatever it is uh my business his
business collects a bunch of unique
information and he made like a bunch of
atomic pieces of content sort of media
company as a way to get his brand and so
90 of the people I read his media will
never buy subscription but his media is
spread around everywhere just like
there's a ton of people are going to
read your Hampton blog you know
obviously I think you should do a
podcast if you do [__] short form
whatever it's like that's going to be
spread out like that and then you know
one percent five percent of those are
going to convert to members and like the
more members you have the more data you
have the more data you have the more
members you have and just keeps going so
to answer your question I just hit
episode 300 I've read over 300
biographies of entrepreneurs so far uh I
have that's over a hundred thousand
pages
what I realized is like over time I'd
input all my highlights into this app
called read wise and so everything you
see externally are just uh they're
essentially uh highlights that I like
the one I I posted yesterday we were
talking about Bloomberg and I was like
oh [__] let me go and uh read back
through my highlights on Bloomberg and I
found one where he said that like you
know if you you should try to love what
you do because you love what you do you
do a lot and then you know that
compounds everything and I put that out
and like immediately these hit and then
people discover the podcast and they
start listening and so me and you and
Bloomberg are kind of running the same
idea but in you know different uh
different Industries or different like
dude I use up until like I so two years
ago up until two years ago I was reading
a ton and then I uh so I like to listen
to books I like to listen I'll listen I
have one that I'm listening to and one
that I read at night and I like to
listen while I'm on walks and there's
this one narrator who I love have you
ever listened to Titan or uh
Vanderbilt's book uh Tycoon he uh the
narrator is awesome and so I was like I
love this narrator he's so good so I
went and found books just by that
narrator and I started scrolling through
and I'm like Oh my God this guy's done
1500 books or something like that that
is narrated and it's like how to win
friends and influence and like all these
like businessy self-helpy books and then
I go and looked at his LinkedIn and I'm
like huh
he's reading all these books why is any
more successful
and I'm like I'm like huh I done worse
so I got angry so now I I now I I read
mostly for fun
and if I don't like something I I I
brush it off I put it away uh and so I
quit reading non-fiction books now I
strictly read biographies or history so
your friend Ryan holiday has a great
post where he shared like his top 25
um biography recommendations and his the
the intro to that post is excellent
because he's like listen you go to the
most successful people in the world look
at their bookshelves they read a lot of
[__] they all read biographies
at all of them without exception he's
like some of the most high value
um reading you can do you notice that as
you read through the biographies like
they're all doing this now here's the
thing
um this uh this actually clicked for me
the other day uh you know Eric jergensen
right
yeah yeah yeah he helped Naval write the
thing yep so he gave me this fantastic
book recommendation I had missed despite
this game Peter bevelin and he kind of
it's a book on Buffett and Monger it's
called uh it's just all I want to know
is where I'll die so I don't go there
and there was something that buff and
Monger were saying in that book that
really clicked for me they kept saying
it's like listen we're going to share
everything we know with you guys we know
that most of you are just gonna listen
or read it and never do anything and I
thought about that for a long time I was
like oh so learning is not memorizing
information like the guy you were just
describing learning is changing your
behavior if you don't change your
behavior that you didn't actually learn
and so therefore I'm not applying the
lessons I'm learning in this book from
my own business then that means I'm just
wasting my whole [__] life because
I'm I'm working on the seven days a week
like I'm giving a lot of my life better
sheet to this and I think that's the
important part is it's like not just
these people didn't just [__] read
they took this idea like okay how can I
apply it to my business and then they
actually change their [__] Behavior
which is like the key no and I've done
that a ton I mean I'll what I my the
reason I read biographies is I look for
patterns and I say uh what mistake did
this person make and how do I avoid it
and where do they win and how do I like
lean in on that and then like the way
that I kind of this sounds really lame
but we make a joke that I'm I call
myself a manifest Cowboy because I love
the redneck but the reason being is I'm
pretty good at like setting five year
and 10-year goals and staying focused
and working backwards to achieve it and
like I can like there's this one book by
how to get rich by Felix Dennis love
them and like I I like listen I was like
all right and he and he was uh he had
cancer I believe or uh I don't know if
he had a cancer when he wrote it but he
died soon after and he was like if I
could do it all over again
I would try to be financially secure by
age 35 and then just puts around and
I was like okay let's do that and so I
like just worked backwards so like how
do you just like have like the bills
handled and then everything else is just
you know icing on the cake and so I'm
pretty good at that but I uh when's the
last time you read it
I read it all the time I refer I use it
like a textbook so like when I think
about like um
equity and how much to pay people I go
and read the sections that he talks
about so I have it if you just Google
how to get rich free pdf there's like a
website that has it so I've bought many
copies and I have a bunch of his
biographies but I'll just like refer to
that all the constantly I'm like all
right what did he say about this and he
gives like pretty practical advice like
on company credit cards like how do you
is your company credit cards and like uh
office space and so I refer back to it
constantly Andrew Wilkinson gave me
advice he's like uh what he did he's
like I read the book before I got rich
and then you read it after you get
really rich
I thought that was really great advice
we uh so you and I are both UFC fans
yeah and I was asking you I was like
what should we talk about and I was like
I want to talk about the difference
between
the people who are pretty good and
absolute Killers yeah and you are like
oh that's just like a new FC that's kind
of the same way but I because I'm
fascinated with like I listened to your
uh I think his name is Sam bronfman the
guy who started sea girls which
eventually turned into like all these
other things and then
I was [__] Savage he's a Savage you
know like he almost reminded me of
myself not in the Savage sense but he
did a few funny things he uh he was like
a Hermit and he like didn't go anywhere
unless his wife went with him and I'm
the same way I'm like I don't go out
unless my wife Cuts up me because I have
like some social anxiety a little bit
and like but when it came to business he
was like pretty uh Brash and um uh like
told people exactly what he thought uh
except like when it came to social
situations he was like super not
confrontational if I go to the grocery
store and I don't see what I'm looking
for I leave I don't ask you know what I
mean I'm like I'm like dude I just don't
even want to ask for help because it
bothers me
um but anyway I listened to him and then
I listened to Napoleon that one was
really good oh dude look at this book
sorry uh Sam Altman said the best book
he's read in the last few years is this
one it's really hard to find it's first
published in 1955. is that the concise
history one I can't see no no no I'm
about I'm gonna do this in like two
um two probably two episodes called the
mind and Napoleon it's it's Napoleon's
old [__] words
and that's cool yeah so because you say
everybody's obsessed with Sam Holton
right now because the chat GPD I didn't
mean to interrupt you but Napoleon's
well Napoleon has this amazing saying I
forget if I heard it from you or or Ben
Wilson but it was something like um
uh you he he was talking to someone who
goes you and I are not the same I am
born of a people of conquerors or
something like that like he had this
like uh like this he felt like he was
just like I'm here to conquer get out of
my way and he had that at a young age
and I thought that was really insightful
um there is something that you picked up
on where
people it's fascinating how like uh
you'll listen to Founders you read a
bunch of biographies and you realize
like the most successful people in the
world you're like oh I don't I don't
want their life and that's the way I
feel like for sure out of like exactly
first of all you said something that's
really smart too it's like people dis
like manifestation or visualization and
they think it's like like Willie
nonsense okay that's fine I can just
tell you pops up in the books over and
over and over again I told you yesterday
I'm reading this [__] insane
biography of Tiger Woods this dude is
like eight years old listening to
motivational tapes writing it out and on
his wall it's like I am powerful I will
achieve my goals like over and over and
over again and you see this from
edwinland Steve Jobs Estee Lauder uh Bob
noyce founder of Intel Arnold
Schwarzenegger have you read the
education I want to send you I was going
to ask you for your address to send you
this book but it's like he might have
already read it did you ever read the
education of a bodybuilder I've heard
about it I've never read it it the first
113 pages is it functions as a as a
autobiography of Arnold when he's 30.
and like the visual utilization thing
seeing things and like he said he's like
he would lay in bed at night and just
picture himself on the stage holding the
trophy of the Mr Universe or whatever in
his hand everybody's like essentially
like bowing down to him he's a conqueror
to use like that example what I find is
that a lot of the people that um like
Felix Dennis man uh I think his the
advice he gave was wise like that guy
had a hole in his heart that could never
fail he spent a hundred million dollars
in a decade 10 million a year on cocaine
alcohol and prostitutes yeah you know
like that's a [__] crazy story in
that book and he what I love about
autobiographies entrepreneurs usually
they write them towards end their life
they don't hide [__] they're like I was
[__] up I was a bad father I cheated
on my wife I whatever you know
um so the the tie this into like the UFC
thing and and the like the Conquering is
that quote um I think it's uh I am of
the race that founds Empires is what it
is so I want to read this quote that you
and I are uh discussing where I think
Joe Rogan is obviously like the world
the world leading expert on you know MMA
like the stuff I wish I could talk to
that guy just I hope I get down I hope I
get the chance just to ask him I
wouldn't I just want to talk about MMA
and all this [__] that's in his brain
and
I was very curious what was going to
happen with this Jon Jones surreal gain
fight right so for those who don't know
Jon Jones is this very controversial
character at age like 22 23 he was like
the first UFC fighter sponsored by Nike
he was the Golden Boy he was the
champion when he was 20 or something and
he's just a killer never lost but he you
know has hit his girlfriend before he's
gotten arrested for drinking and driving
he's a mess he's a killer on and off uh
the field did you ever see the video of
him where remember like during the the
pandemic people were like lighting [__]
on fire there's all these riots and they
did it in uh Albuquerque where he's at
and he stopped him yeah you saw that
could you imagine if those two guys
there's two small guys like young kids
like spray painting and vandalizing [__]
and John is just walking around like
give me the can give me the can give me
the can like dude if you know who that
is you'll give him the cans
Jon Jones is like six two probably well
now he weighs 260 pounds I mean he's
like one of the scarier people you could
ever see and he's athletic the guy's a
freak he's a freak but he comes off this
is why this is interesting he he he
tries to come off like a nice guy a lot
of times in interviews and he and when
you listen to him talk you think all
right at least I think this is learned
behavior and you are actually a more
sociopathy than you are not and you will
kill someone easily and sleep like a
baby at night 100 so this is the
fascinating thing about setting history
so this is what Joe Brogan said about
John Jones which I think is gonna it
reminds me like a young Bill Gates which
we can talk about he says Joe Joe's like
listen there's human beings that have a
ruthless competitive drive that is
terrifying to the ordinary person Jon
Jones is a bad guy who is trying to be a
good guy if he were living a thousand
years ago he'd be on a horse with a
battle ax chopping the heads off of
everyone and everyone would be running
these dominators have always existed
he's a [__] conqueror that is the
thing that's inside of him that lead
needs them to be the goat greatest of
all time without that you don't get
there there's a thing inside of some
people there's a driving force that
allows them to overcome the greatest
people around them when I heard that I
wasn't thinking about Jon Jones I was
thinking like that's Michael Jordan
that's Jeff Bezos that's a young Bill
Gates that's Edward land that's aren't
uh John Rockefeller that's Carnegie
that's all of them they had they have
this ruthless competitive drive to me
they're a different species than an
average person
um and so the example of that is like I
did this uh this excellent biography of
the young girl Gates right in my opinion
the perfect biography it's like I don't
need to know what their great
grandfather did for a living right it's
like tell me the struggle the reason
we're alert like give me a little
background to what family they were born
into then tell me the struggle and then
once they're rich and the book and so
there's a book called hard drive Bill
Gates in the making of Microsoft Empire
that covers the first 35 years of though
beats life right so it ends right after
the Microsoft IPO and I'm obsessed the
reason I have a solo podcast uh is
because my podcast Idol is Dan Carlin
Hardcore History right and is he by
himself
100 he's got a giant audience
um we should actually talk about
podcasting if you're interested in that
he he a lot of people share numbers
he had said uh don't let me forget the
thread on Bill Gates By the way um he
had said
the latest episode this is like two
years ago uh
that got published he got 19 million
downloads on and then he said oh wait
then he said oh wait uh it turns out
some of them were double counted so in
any case cut it in half it's nine he's
got an audience of probably 10 million
people that listen to him that would be
one of the biggest episodes of the year
for most every podcast yes you know the
big dogs get a million or 1.5 per
episode but rarely you know Joe Rogan if
he interviewed like burnt when he
interviewed Bernie Sanders or someone
like that that maybe got five or or
eight or something like that
so Joe Joe's audience and Joe has more
data than anybody else and all the
Spotify exclusives has more data
anywhere else he said uh remember when
they tried to cancel him this is also
the magical podcasting man uh which I
know we don't like we we have to be
careful here because we talk about it
forever
um
the problem is is like you have people
that don't if you listen to Joe or you
listen like I listen to you and [__]
Sean forever I know even before we met I
like I know who you guys are no manifest
Cowboy I know the [__] terminology we
have an idea of who you are like the
person before you meet them right that's
the magic of podcasting it's like we're
not creating content we're creating
relationships at scale which is very
[__] powerful and still on people
most people don't they they understand
how powerful this is
um and so what happens like you have you
know people saying Joe Rogan's racist
you know they they cut the clip and then
you know he's anti-backs everything else
and so they try to cancel them and then
somebody's been listening to him for
[__] 10 years and listens to him 10
hours a week he's like you're not gonna
tell me anything about Joe that I don't
know and so what happens is he said his
audience added too many people I think
he went from 12 million subscribers to
14 million subscribers on Spotify those
are the numbers I've heard yeah
um and it speaks to like this he's still
the biggest by far because even like the
top you know human to everybody else
like years 1.5 without YouTube and
everything else so there's still just
crazy how big and successful Joe show is
um but what about Bill the like the bill
uh so Bill Gates is I was doing an
episode on him and I had just been
listening to Dan Carlin's uh Wrath of
the cons series on gang of Khan for like
the 15th time
and it I realized it's like oh
like you you see Bill Gates
is like this is Genghis Khan in a Mr
Rogers costume he's in a disguise and he
is unbelievably Relentless so there's
this guy named Michael Moritz who was uh
now he's a billionaire uh he's one of
the guys that helped scale Sequoia but
at the time he's just a journalist
this is a perfect example he's giving uh
he just drove us I think he's writing
for Time Magazine and he's meeting bill
you know Bill's probably made let's see
28 something like that they do an
interview Bill's like hey I'll give you
right to the airport they get in Bill's
Car and Michael's like oh [__] somebody
broke into your car what happened here
he's like what are you talking about he
goes your radio it's like somebody stole
your radio
he's like no I I ripped it out he said
why would you do that he's like from my
house to Microsoft Office is seven
minutes that's 14 minutes a day from
Microsoft's office to the airport I go
there three times a week that's 15
minutes around trip you know 30 30 min
or 15 minutes she's ready 30 minutes
round trip and he has this episode so
that's like two hours in the car and if
I have a radio then I'd listen to it and
then I'm spending two hours not thinking
about Microsoft
and there's all these [__] crazy
stories because somebody asked the other
day like what's the largest bootstrap
business of all time and Paul Graham
answered Microsoft
and people are like oh they took VC no
no they were creating money and they
sold a million shares of Microsoft for a
million dollars to a VC they did not
need the money right before they went
public to get expertise that was a
bootstrap business the year before this
is in 1980 money the year before
Microsoft IPOs they did 140 million in
revenue and 38 million profit that's
insane right he's the same and then so
this extreme Jon Jones the zero game
thing when you hear about how he thinks
about his [__] competitors it's not
just enough that he needs to win he's
like I have to [__] destroy you so
there's this spooky [__] um
the spooky story that's in one of Bill
Gates biographies I've read two of them
and uh bill would be able to tell you
like in the software industry he's like
I know the CEO of every single software
company I know what the revenue was I
know what their where their product is
right now I know everything about them
and so they all they have a bunch of
like frenemies he's like I want to
destroy you but he would talk to you and
a lot of them were getting customers at
these in the early days of like these uh
these software uh conventions which is
very like very new
and so this guy Philippe Khan that he
was trying to [__] destroy he
literally wants to put you out of
business because he told his employees
like if I if we lose a 50 000 contract
that's not fifty thousand that's a
hundred thousand because we lost 50 and
our [__] enemy got 100 got 50. so you
just cost 300 000 she was like that's
psychotic about it and so Philippe goes
over sees Bill sitting by himself in
like a foldable chair just looking at
something
Philippe walks up to him and he goes say
hi to Bill and he realizes what Bill's
looking at
he's looking at a picture of Philippe
Khan
he's in public in a [__] corner of a
Convention Center staring at a [__]
picture of his enemy like the what Joe
said about John a thousand years ago we
lived a zero sum if you want to build
wealth what'd you do like you took their
land or took their results somebody else
yes yeah so a thousand years ago that
personality type Bill Gates would have
been leaky would have been in Napoleon
he would have been leading an army it
just so happens that this same
personality type that is that exists
today has existed forever will exist
forever in the future can run companies
and build wealth
and when you when you study the
personalities of these people it's like
they're all like that thank God we are
living a free market economy or else
there'd be they'd be pillaging and
raping and doing everything else well
that's why my favorite era of American
history is like
um 1890 so that's uh uh 30 or 20 years
after the Civil War so America is kind
of getting back to it up until like 1920
because in 1920
um like the Sherman Act which was the
anti-monopoly ACT uh started coming
about and then the SEC was invented and
so between like 1890 and 1920 America
was really the wild west where we had
some technology you know we had cars we
had I think phones were coming about
Telegraph so we could railroads
railroads and the stock market what
existed so we could like make wealth but
there's a few things that you could do
so for example Andrew Carnegie and um uh
who's his partner Frick like Henry Clay
Frick yeah like when people would uh
when the union workers would boycott and
protest they killed them like they they
hired a private police team and they
went on a private Army and they
literally beat like 10 of them to death
and I don't think anything happened I
don't know if anything happened no
because they also owned the politicians
yeah and it was wild and then like there
was a time where JP Morgan loaned the
U.S government money and and then there
was a time a lot of people don't know
this but JFK John John F Kennedy the uh
president his father Joe Kennedy was
like the seventh richest man in America
at one point he got rich from insider
trading then after he was already rich
he created or he was the first head of
the SEC that made insider trading
illegal like it was like hardcore crony
capitalism that's one of the reasons why
I like reading about John Rockefeller is
because
of all the things he did he was
dishonest once or twice but for the most
part he was a ruthless competitor and he
didn't lie and he was honest other than
uh one big time he lied but besides that
he was pretty straight and how crazy was
it that his employees net he did like he
never we never heard him raise his voice
and he never said an unkind word to us
now his competitors different story he's
completely ruthless with them but inside
of his you're not going to find anybody
that worked inside of Standard Oil and
then obviously they hid all the things
they owned
there's actually an idea I stole from uh
by the way his competitors he wasn't
really I mean he was ruthless but he
would go to them he goes hey I would
like to buy you this is a very fair
price come and join me and I'll make you
rich of which many did and they got rich
and he said if you don't join me I'm
gonna destroy you so let me know if you
and so to me that's like he's like look
we can work together or I'm gonna end
you you can pick but he wasn't like
necessarily like rude about it yeah so
the one thing he said was so badass he
was trying to buy somebody out they
resisted he's like I have ways to make
money that you know nothing about he was
yeah I always say like there's a there's
a very common theme that common themes
are Reaper in the history
entrepreneurship and so I have maxims
for a bunch of these like my favorite
one is Excellence this is capacity to
take pain it's just like you're not
gonna achieve
large success without being able to
tolerate paint for extended periods of
time right another one is bad boys
moving silence like they find an
advantage and they shut up about it this
is what um Steve Jobs realized when he
was built trying to build Pixar he's
just like we can't get any [__] data
on how profitable because you have to
transitioning for selling Hardware to
just pure anime like trying to build the
first computer animated movie and Steve
Jobs like I don't get why like we can't
get any information on this and then he
realized he's like oh the reason that
you can't go to the library and check
out a book that says like the business
model of Animation is because there's
only one company ever did well and it's
Disney and they don't want anybody else
to know how lucrative it is and so he
realized that because they had they had
made like Snow White like 60 years
before and right when he's doing his
negotiations with Pixar and Disney they
re-released it and we're selling like
VHS tapes and I think that they might
have had DVDs at this point and they're
like wait a minute you sold 28 million
copies of a movie you made 60 years ago
that's all profit and they made two he
said they made a quarter billion profit
on that one movie releasing it for like
the new technology and so I actually
took an idea from Johnny Rockefeller Rob
Moore plays a role in this is like uh
what what um Rockefeller would do is
like he had the secret allies right and
so he
entered into an industry that he thought
was very disorganized and so he wound up
building relationships and allies with
all the people in the oil remember the
oil business when he jumps in it's not
what we think is oil he was like he was
over fire he was selling kerosene for
[__] like lighting and stuff he made
up he actually made more money in
retirement because after he retired he
still owned a [__] ton of um Equity goes
back to Felix Dennis uh and then the
ambition of the core and so now like oh
this this my my Stock's even worth more
uh but what he would do is he'd go
around and he'd organize all the other
people in the industry so like I did
this with a bunch of podcasters like me
and you just started doing this like
texting about this it's just like you
just share information like you build
secret allies and you just say hey this
guy figured out this for your podcast
you should use it and like everybody in
the podcast industry is extremely
positive some I listen to your um your
interview with Brandon Shaw he said the
same thing about he's like Joe told us
we have an obligation to help each other
out and so for business podcast it's
like they're all kind of like satellites
and like Loosely defined and so me and
Patrick have been going around building
relationships to people and just sharing
information like I was at the acquire
guy's house in San Francisco a few weeks
ago they're like we give Patrick
they have one of the most profitable
Ben and David who are fantastic I'm
actually wearing their merch right now
um they have one of the most profitable
podcasts and compared to audience size
so how much they make and they're like
well Patrick told us that we weren't
charging enough so we tripled our prices
then we and then we still sold ads and
then we tripled them again and then it's
like holy [__] he was right and so that
idea is like we're no gatekeeping just
share information and try to help people
as much as possible
um that's an idea from Rockefeller when
you read about some of these killers do
you think they are different than me or
do you start becoming that like do you
think that uh just surrounding yourself
with them is going to change your
behavior or is it just like aliens exist
and I am not them no here's the thing we
I don't know if we're recording I like
how you guys just Jump Right In by the
way
um so I don't I think most of our
discussion was caught on recording but
um I am very glad that I have a wife and
two kids
um up and down like here's here's my
thing it's like the thing that I don't
like and it's very present all these
books is like if you're an adult
it's your job to figure it out and like
not let people take advantage of you
right so if like John D Rockefeller
gives you a bad price and for your
business you accept it that's on you
what I'm and you hear this on the
podcast like I'm induced since the state
of rages when people [__] with kids I
can't stand them and so up and down my
family tree like I was the first person
to graduate high school in my family
much less College I'm the first uh male
and my three generations not to go to
jail right and so like up and down both
sides of my family tree I just see a lot
of like
terrible parenting and this is not
necessarily my parents they did the best
they can consider both sets of their
parents were shitty people but like I
saw drug abuse I saw sexual abuse I saw
people going to jail cocaine all this
crazy [__] right and so
I was like if I'm gonna have kids I'm
not going to be a [__] father and I
think the fact that I have a kid and a
wife is that like we get along really
well it saves me from not I think if I
didn't have that I would literally work
from the time I
eyes open in the morning till the time
they close
and I would just [__] like I think
the scary part is like I and I try to
prepare myself to you know you can't
compare myself to Rockefeller so but
like
I have a little bit of that in me too
and I think I hear from a ton of people
listen
they're like I think like that too the
whole thing is like learning from their
experience like hey but they get to
their life they're not necessarily happy
you know like so I don't want that
um I don't want to destroy everything
around me
because I I chased professional success
but I think men in general you know type
A aggressive men like that's what
successful people super successful
people are crazy like they're not normal
humans and it's probably one to five
percent of the population that are
borderline sociopathic you know nothing
motor people that's that's a little bit
extreme but like they're willing to do
whatever they can if you get in their
way and so I I'm I've been lucky that as
we've it's it's funny that as we've I've
gotten more popular for like content and
business [__] A lot of people in
different fields who I previously looked
up to like for example a Lance Armstrong
or someone like that uh they'll like
message me and I'll get an opportunity
to hang out with them and this isn't
about Lance but this is I've been lucky
that it's been a bunch of different
people
and I'll go and hang out with them a
couple of times and then I think I don't
want to be around you ever again like
and so like I don't enjoy being around
them and so I've had a bunch of people
who if you told me when I was 12 that
these people want to talk to me I'd be
like that is sick now I just I'm just
like I don't like being around you it's
actually not enjoyable being around some
of these people
um because it feels like
well I don't know exactly how it feels
like like it feels like we I'm we're in
a pissing match when we're when we're
with each other
um yeah I simply don't enjoy it and so
now I've I have a rule in my household
which is No New Friends
um so I default whenever I talk to
someone I default to I'm not going to be
friends until it's like all right maybe
after a while we can we can we can cross
the threshold but by default it's I
don't trust you and I'm not going to let
you in
um whereas before it was like oh anyone
who wants to holler at me yeah I'm in
and then I go and hang out with some of
these Ballers and these killers and I
think oh this is this is a very
unenjoyable hang you know there's a
bunch of people who
maybe Ben might know who we're talking
about um but there's like a couple
people that are like some of the most
famous and successful people in the
world and we've been lucky to hang out
with them and then we'll go hang out
with them after the Pod and I'm like oh
this is just miserable I don't want to
be around you at all and so my point
being is
for the the to what what you said about
the most successful people being crazy
not only are they crazy I don't want to
be around them it's not fun they're not
fun to be around and so you really see
that there's a price to pay which is you
are in the one percentile or 99
percentile of this of these other traits
which usually not always means you're
going to be lacking in a handful of
other traits and sometimes that's like
whatever the traits are of you wanting
to be near someone I guess like
physically and hanging out with someone
that that's my thing everybody's like
okay uh like are you doing all this are
you gonna do you want to run like the
next apple like what are you doing this
for and I'm like no like out of the 300
people that I've studied the the person
that I want to be the most like is the
the closest person
that I've studied and read about that
has come to mastering life is a guy
named ed Thorpe right and so it's a
[__] this is a [__] crazy story so
it's episode 222 and the crazy thing is
like usually the episode title is just
the book I read right this says my
personal blueprint right and because
what he did is like first of all he's a
Ed Thorpe is one he was the guy that
made the first quantitative hedge fund
right uh the reason I liked him is
because
what I think you were talking about
earlier like you have varied interests
right where you need a balance because
I've also heard you speak enough where
I'm like okay he's clearly type A and
driven and like if you didn't have your
wife or you didn't have these other
things I could also see you going I'm
not sociopathic but like you know no
limit to the kind of Empire you want to
build you have a chip on your shoulders
just like all of them I do too so I see
that
um
Ed Thorpe essentially like what he did
is like he made a ton of money as a
quantitative investor right but once he
had more money like he didn't need to
worry about money anymore he refused to
trade time to make more money because he
understood he's like more money's not
gonna make me happy but my time his
limit he was a good father he was a good
husband he was he followed his own
intellectual interests like he had fun
he
uh Tim Ferriss just interviewed him and
I would highly recommend going to
YouTube and just type in Tim Paris at
Thorpe and look at that guy's picture
and tell me how old you think he is I've
done this a bunch I did with my wife I
go how old do you think he is she said I
don't know 65. he's [__] 90. because
he learned when he was really young that
physical fitness was really important
and so he gave me the best heuristic uh
Health he goes I view every hour in the
gym as one less day I'll spend in the
hospital at the end of my life and the
guy's still doing like pull ups he looks
[__] fantastic right he's like no I
think he might be like 92.
um and so this whole balance of like
your friend Ryan holiday actually I
learned this from his content was like
what it means to be a completed human
we've known that forever we just get
distracted it's like you want work that
has meaning you want good relationships
you want to have fun and you want to
make sure that your body is healthy and
you feel good that's it there isn't
anything else I love what you just said
because the same thing when you have a
successful podcast you get hit up on all
kinds of [__] crazy experiences which
is actually you know a huge benefit but
it's like man I'm not going to build a
thousand relationships that are like an
inch deep I just talked to the same
people over and over and over and over
again it's like you have a limited
amount of people you can actually be
friends with and yet we're all connected
so like we're hugely distracted so I was
like okay I'm not smart as a Thor he's
way smarter than me so I'll just [__]
copy his blueprint I'll write that down
I'll be a good father I'll be a good
husband I'll take care of my health I'll
have work that I'm really [__]
obsessed with but I put guardrails on
right and like I'm not going to keep
trading money or time which I'm going to
run out of for more money when I'm not
even spending the money I have
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobbled
together
spot is easy to adopt and actually looks
gorgeous I think I love our new CRM our
software is the best HubSpot grow better
I want to um I want to ask you some more
questions about history but a story
really quick I I have a friend who's
40 low 40s worth a billion dollars has a
publicly traded company
and he was telling me the story about
how
he had this phrase called It's never
enough and he was telling me a story
about how he went to one guy's home who
was worth 50 million and the guy was
complaining about how he lives in this
fancy neighborhood and he can't his home
is his six million dollar home is less
good than is worse than the other people
in the neighborhood then he's like I
went to another guy who's worth like
half a billion and he was saying like
yeah but you know what I don't have a
super yacht and then there was another
guy who had like one or two billion and
this guy was complaining he's like can't
get a sports team though it's not enough
and so yeah I don't want to be around
people I think you hit it don't be like
I don't want to be around people like
that It's never enough and that's what
I've also learned because like I've
thought that when I've hit certain
points I'm like well I won't want
anymore it's you always want more it's a
very challenging thing it doesn't have
to be that way though I had the
advantage because like this is the crazy
thing about podcasts you just said like
you never know who's listening so I got
uh invited to have uh to our lunch with
samzo right and that's [__] crazy
um it came inbound Sam had listened to
the podcast I made on his autobiography
and he's like I want to meet that guy
Sam's a real estate guy he's got a great
book called uh am I being loud enough or
am I being subtle all right am I being
set off yeah am I being subtle enough
he's uh he's probably close to 90 now
he's kind of anyone he's kind of got
this blue collar-ish Vibe about him but
he's worth probably five or ten billion
dollars something like that he owned uh
uh all these real estate things he
created the Reit I think then he like
owned Schwinn bicycles he owned the LA
Times I think or the Tribune something
like that he's so he's like a tycoon
he's so you're and you'd [__] love
them so he's 81 years old he sold his
his real estate company for 38 billion
to Black roach or Blackstone I don't
[__] know you know they're all being
the same and so you know who the [__]
how often do you get to meet somebody
that sells or company for 40 billion
dollars and I couldn't believe this was
gonna happen I thought it was like oh
like this doesn't really happen now it's
like oh maybe it's gonna be like a lunch
I'm invited to and it's like 20 people
there it's like no he sat eye to eye for
two [__] hours and he's not like that
you would the reason I I got back after
that lunch and I told my wife I go I
want that I want that I want to be 81
years old completely still unbelievably
curious about the world around him still
doing deals doesn't give a [__] he's not
one of these like media trade guys right
he only wears blue jeans I think he
invented he he takes
he takes credits like I invented
business casual I'm like Sam what the
[__] I don't know if it's invented his
schedule this [__] hilarious that you
would say that you invented business
casual will not wear a suit still rides
a motorcycle
ah still I think smoked weed let's it's
[__] crazy but the thing the advice
that he gave me he's like
David he's like the Richer you get what
you realize is one he goes you'd be
shocked at how many Rich guys I know
that aren't having fun which is
describing exactly what you're saying
you go to their house and they're
talking about other people or what other
people have I'd run the other [__]
way Sam didn't talk about that he goes
listen he goes money he's like there's
very few true luxuries in like the
Richer he got he's like then I just kept
just buying nicer of the same [__] so
I'd buy a house then if I get richer and
then buy another house like this was
[__] stupid so he's like I basically
own nothing he has a place in Chicago
and he has a compound in Malibu that's
his words by the way because he's like I
have a compound of Malibu
um he's like just he's like the advice
he gave me over and everything he said
five or six times every two hours he's
like optimized for Freedom if you get
Freedom you get to choose what you do
and then you have fun and if you have
fun you'll be really good at it and the
money will come but do not give up your
freedom for money which so many Rich
dudes do it's [__] crazy and then he
goes the one thing he's like none of
that [__] matters I could buy everything
I want he goes I rent a bunch of [__]
which reminded me of you because I know
you [__] hate owning a house and so
it's like renting yeah he's like don't
own a bunch of [__] just rent it when
you eat it like because if you own it
you gotta take care of it this is advice
from [__] the guy that you know
obviously on assets he was by he's still
buying a ton of businesses the day
before I saw him he he's like he's dude
he's 81 he just his eyes lit up he's
like I just 300 million dollars buying
75 of this company makes 50 million a
year or some [__] like he just loves the
deal he's like I'm gonna be doing deals
so I die just because he likes the game
he's like he treats it like a game but
he's like there's only one true luxury
in life he goes try to get the private
jet money
really what what are what was it like
meeting Charlie Munger
so that was [__] crazy too
um and again because like Andrew and his
partner Chris
um it was fascinating because uh I heard
your podcast where you guys had met
Chris and spent time with them
um and I got to have the the the the few
hours before we had dinner with Charlie
Munger I had like a super long lunch
one-on-one with Chris and that dude is
fascinating I wonder if he'd ever come
on your podcast if you want to hang out
with him tonight I want to be with him
tonight okay yeah like you should I know
he's more private he's another guy where
I think he knows like one of the things
I loved about Chris now he's wicked
smart but one of the things I thought
was so cool is like he showed me his
calendar when we had lunch he's like
look at my calendar it's like every day
at three o'clock I'm picking my I think
it's his son his son up from school like
he's not going to be you know he's like
obviously rich and successful will
continue to be more rich and more
successful as he carries on
um but he's not doing it at the
detriment of being a shitty dad which
like I admire a lot [__] hate shitty
dads so what was Munger like he was he
was present so Monger was uh he has this
line where he's like oh I didn't succeed
in life because of intelligence I
succeeded because of a long attention
span definitely has a long attention
span but that dude is way smarter than
me like if anybody's even even at 98 or
what how old is he 95 so he's 99 anybody
is going to have uh some level of
cognitive decline at 99. and so all I
could think about is like if that is who
he is a 99 imagine trying to compete
with that dude 30 years ago what was his
house like I I have to be careful
because I got into a little bit of like
they want me to keep some of this up
private so like I can't answer that
question was it fancy was it uh was it
as you'd expect which is very very very
nice no he lit he's very authentic he if
you read monger and talk about Monger
he's like hey don't have a lot of silly
needs in your life uh his whole thing is
like I truly believe that he just wanted
to show what he could do with his brain
so he could make a ton of money with his
mind because he's really smart he like
wears like you know he loves flannel in
your in your picture I think like a
channel from Amazon so the Costco like
his one of shared entrees Jim Senegal
well I love a lot too and one of his
favorite companies Jim Senegal or it's
Costco because of that Costco could have
made more money but past the the benefit
of their group buying onto the customer
and so Charlie's who he says he is he's
like he's not doesn't have a fancy watch
doesn't have fancy clothes he just
buys books as far as I can tell and
talks to interesting people and makes a
ton of money but he's not in it for the
money he just wanted he's in he says
he's like I didn't want the Ferraris I
wanted the independence who all that
you've so besides Ed Thorpe who all have
you
Who Have you listened to or uh spoken
about that you think is like in your top
five people of like
they will conquer the world if given the
chance like they're they are the the the
top they are the one percent of the one
percent I mean I think the selection
here is that every single person is in
the top you know point zero zeros or
what percent because you're only the
only to get on Founders you have to live
a life from work well somebody wrote a
book about it what I would say is like
I just got done reading James Dyson's
autobiography for the fourth time and it
is my number one book recommendation by
far for entrepreneurs and he's written
two autobiographies the second one's
fine there's nothing wrong with that I'm
done with the first one because the
first one he writes after 14 years of
struggle like what I admire so much
about this guy is like he's not
necessarily like a conqueror in a sense
like he's gonna go around
I don't think he'd be like a Napoleon in
other times but what I loved is like my
favorite entrepreneurs or very adamant
about what they want to do in life and
how they want to run their business it's
not formulaic they're not going around
asking people advice like what do you
think I should do what does my product
look like what is how should I run the
business like no I have a very set
uh mindset of like how I want to build
the product how I want to build my
business how I want to to uh to like
spend my time you know I call that they
Bend reality to their to their will you
know they kick their debt in the
universe that's what I always call that
I'm like they know what they want and
they bent reality to fit what they
wanted read that dude who read his
autobiography in a weekend it'll [__]
blow your mind because it's like why is
this guy not quitting well what is what
is happening here he's barring he's got
two mortgages on every single house he's
got he's crying at the end of the night
and everything he's gonna be successful
and he just won't quit and what happens
is like you fast forward now James Dyson
is 75 years old he owns 100 of Dyson
company he's like you know one that
company's probably worth 20 billion
dollars it makes supposedly you know a
couple billion a year for profit for his
family that like they take out of the
company what I love is um he the company
he owned before Dyson vacuums it was
this thing called a ball Barrow which
looks like a wheelbarrow with a ball at
the front and he goes and rents uh does
a photo shoot for the ball Barrow
at this like massive estate that has
been in England for like 300 years
25 years later he buys it he's like this
is my [__] now
like dude I I've talked to a lot of
people who love that book one thing that
one thing so I remember like when I've
just got started in my career I was like
firmly in the in the field of like I'm
gonna pull myself up for my bootstraps
and I'm gonna I'm gonna make this into
existence and then I remember when we
were selling our company and everything
got done
and that was the first time in my life
where I thought
luck is so important and even though I I
think I'm a badass and that I would and
I think that I could will myself to a
very
I think I can will myself to a really
nice amount of success but in order to
have the Uber success which we'll
describe as like liquid hundreds of
millions of dollars
there's lots of people who are these
types of killers who do have these
attribute attributes but one or two
things both in their control and out of
their control went wrong or right and
that can absolutely change things like
it could be like
like you know John Rockefeller didn't
know that a car was going to be invented
uh or like with with Zuckerberg like he
would have kicked ass no matter what but
it just so happened that like the phone
came out and that like has helped a ton
or uh you know someone like what you
know I'm sure we've seen a lot of
Fortunes get created during a pandemic
like luck is real like when we sold our
company
and that was my first big win the CEO
Brian got into a nearly fatal accident
afterwards and I'm like dude if that
happened like four weeks prior I don't
know if this would have gone through and
I still think I will be very successful
but imagine if I was selling my company
for a billion or two billion dollars and
the CEO of the buyer got killed or quit
do you think that with these guys luck
is real of course you you said something
great on the acquired podcast you're
like I've met a lot of these guys it's
like they're 20 times richer but they're
not 20 times smarter yeah and a lot of
Rockefeller is a great example right
like so uh the best way to describe is
like moderate level success like you
know you could probably get to tens of
millions of dollars in net worth that's
like playing poker right it's like
that's a skill set you can get but like
two like Jeff Bezos like the funniest
thing I had dinner last night with two
Founders was like you guys know that
Jeff Bezos was private jet has a private
jet like he takes off and there's
another one like that level of [__] like
there's so many things I gotta break the
idea is like he knew he was gonna why
does he have a second private jet I'd
love to ask him I don't know like so you
know how this is like people track
private jets now some YouTuber made a
video and they noticed that every time
Jeff's playing maybe it's like the
people who doesn't want on his plane I
don't [__] know but like there's a
jet that follows his other jet around
and like it's somebody put all this
together from public information so uh
that level of success like he knew okay
the internet's growing we the everything
store was a code name in the hedge fund
he for Amazon they they were going to
incubate it in the hedge fund he was
working for David Shaw a billionaire uh
hedge fund guy in New York and so he
knew he was like we could sell books and
then he also knew he could sell all
those things but likely but he didn't
know like he could invent AWS like there
was no like all that stuff that happens
Rockefeller is a great example Bezos
when he pitched the First Investors he
goes I think this can make 100 million
dollars a year if we're lucky yeah he uh
he he it took him 50 meetings for
adventure capitalist to get his first
million dollars and he said the most
common question he was asked is what is
the internet yeah he's a [__] Savvy
he is the closest to me Bezos reminds me
so much of Rockefeller like if you read
bezos's shareholder letters are
excellent uh because he's telling you
what he's just like the the Arnold book
that I recommended earlier Arnold says
this is my blueprint this is when I'm
gonna do he calls a shot and then he
goes and does it Facebook says the same
thing but the Rockefeller 20 times
richer but not 20 times smarter thing I
think it's obviously you're talking
about Randomness you're talking about
luck uh Rockefeller was going to be
successful no matter what like the
business he was in as you know it's like
he was they were wholesaling like
produce and other stuff right they were
just Traders and one thing that he did I
think is really smart is like he's
worked he's like 19 years old working
for two Founders he's just an employee
he goes back and reads all of their
books goes back and studies their entire
company history memorizes all the
finances everything and then knew more
about the business and the founder stud
like that kind of personality is going
to win wherever he's going to go now he
could have stayed in that business and
made millions of dollars is he going to
build the arguably the most successful
company of all time if it wasn't for the
random discovery of oil no
like he didn't control the fact that he
was in the what I would say in the
podcast is like you find these people
that are the right right person
right set of skills at the right place
the right time if you're missing any of
those you're not gonna build you know a
trillion dollar company or uh you know
200 million or 200 billion dollar net
worth you need things to break through
for you that are outside of your
what do you think you're going to do
next like where you know where what's
your blueprint for 10 years
okay so this is where I start talking
Reckless because
um I am probably the most optimistic
person in terms of like how good this of
a business podcasting can be and I
started talking crazy and then I have
some friends uh
uh that have built giant businesses on
the back of podcasts I was at dinner
with them last week and they literally
pulled me to the side they like shut the
[__] up stop telling people all this
[__] so what's an example of a great
business on the back of it I'll tell you
I'll tell you I off I can't like there's
a there's okay there's one that I don't
have any intimate knowledge on uh I can
give you an example of that
um because there's someone that have
intimate knowledge I'm not sure what I
know it's like to speak public and I
don't but like butcher box bootstrap 500
million dollars in Revenue largely
expanded from podcasting and there's a
ton of those uh industry buying podcast
ads yes got it yes
um and then look at I mean this is
something I actually learned on your
podcast which I think you guys did an
excellent job with was uh when you guys
were talking about how Unilever came
about on it
right yeah yeah I didn't I didn't know
that happened I knew about on it I knew
about Joe I I knew he owned like 30
rumor to be on 30 of the company but
think about like Joe has a ton of um ad
slots just that one ad slot that he
randomly put in he probably had just on
that asphalt around 75 million dollars
like depending on what the actual
purchase price was
um Joe so this idea is like I started
talking [__] where like people like
everybody knows because of Mr Beast
thing going oh yeah there's gonna be I
could see why there's gonna be like some
billionaire YouTubers right like that I
think that is obvious now given where Mr
Beast highly likely that dude unless he
dies he's gonna hit that my point is
it's like
that's the the the the deep relationship
people have a podcasters is not
comparable to the relationship they have
YouTubers it's not at all comparable and
this is not at all new what like what
anything that what do you mean doing
people are deeply are more uh they like
podcasters more like there's more
Affinity it's so do you know Blake
Robbins from uh he's at benchmark
no he has this okay so um he'd be
actually interested something
interesting talking he's the one that
gave me the Spectrum idea he's uh helped
incubate uh what's the what's the uh
professional Call of Duty team 100
thieves or 40 thieves oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I know I know you mean they went
from zero to like 80 million in Revenue
I think like 18 months or some [__] like
this so nature was uh developed an
audience on you know Twitch streaming
and so so Blake has this spectrum and
this comes to you like uh there's people
out there that have heard you and uh
Sean talk way more than
they've heard their best friend's voice
yeah because when they when they put the
headphones in it's just us and them and
it's usually for 50 or an hour minutes
uh you know 60 Minutes at a time whereas
a YouTube video it's uh maybe eight I've
heard you talk for a hundred hours like
so like we've taxed exchanged message
online but never talk in person I was
like oh I [__] know Sam like I know
what he's into we have the same
interests like I think we'll be able to
talk about a bunch of [__] right so his
whole point is like on the spectrum is
like how much do people how much time do
people spend with you he's like on the
far end all the way to the left it's
like Tick Tock dancers right tick tock
dancers you know they might have
millions and millions of followers but
they spend 30 seconds and if they try to
like sell tickets they can't even fill a
room with like 3 000 people even if
there's doubt you know millions of
dollars on the far end of the spectrum
all the way to the right is Twitch
streamers people spend literally 40
hours a week with their favorite trip
streamer right or 30 hours a week or 20
hours he goes David podcast and you
you're just one
uh one one step towards the left he goes
there's gonna be people who have
listened to you speak for hundreds of
hours right and that parasocial
relationship is unbelievably deep and
comprehensive to like you saw this I saw
them people who had said that you're
doing a public Meetup I think in Austin
right and or a show and there's people
flying in from [__] Dubai
yeah it's crazy right okay so think
about that like they're not flying into
Dubai to watch like a tick tock dancer
they're not flying in and your podcast
is technically a business you have all
this other stuff you can do it's like
how many brands do people identify with
so much that they'll fly across the
world I just did this I'm introverted as
[__] right yeah you seem like it yeah so
yeah
yeah but on one-on-one but with groups I
hate it so uh Shane Parish from
knowledge project Runner Street was in
Miami he's like dude let's do a public
Meetup I'm like oh [__] and I agree just
because he's did it how many people came
uh like 70 like I think around like 70
people came it's awkward right it's not
awkward uh I I don't think I'd do it
again but like this is the thing like
the only thing I did to promote it Shane
was supposed to send it out to his
newsletter never did thanks Jane but um
I just made it like this one minute I I
was like like five days before the event
or something I uploaded to my podcast
video I was like hey you happen to be in
Miami area we're gonna do this here's
we're gonna be and like I'm like all
right there's no like my audience is in
like you know California New York so
it's like Miami's not like the spot for
it
people flew down from New York
Washington DC drove for hours and I'm
like what are you in town for like this
I'm like why what what are you talking
about and so it's this deep level
relationship so so here's your question
like my 10-year plan is just like I'm
going to be making podcasts until I
[__] die I love doing it it's the
best job in the world I think Sean
tweeted out something that he's like
podcasting is the best job in the world
it's like you get to be curious to learn
all the time and then you package up
what you learn and you send it out to
the world and all this good benefit
comes back to you you know relationships
investment opportunities businesses you
can launch whatever cases
um and so I'm just going to run the same
Playbook that like Rockefeller does like
right now you scale with ads people pay
a very high dollar amount because your
audience is valuable yeah and thank you
for uh for promoting Hampton uh on your
part of that that was more than my first
car bro
but I appreciate that hey I I look
hopefully you get more hopefully you get
uh more than enough value no that's
that's that's a perfect example I didn't
you wouldn't you didn't have to ask me
to do that because I got so much value
from you the weird thing that you
probably experienced too that this is
people dude the conversation you have
with podcasters you can't if you're not
on this side you don't understand a
listener does not understand the [__]
that like why every single person you
talk to that's podcaster has a
successful podcast is like I'm never
[__] not gonna quit like I'm never
not gonna do this this thing is it's
like magic
um and so when when I was like dude I
think Hampton first of all is a great
idea because
um entrepreneurs have to be around other
entrepreneurs like we do not think like
anybody else you go to you're gonna have
you said you're gonna have a family once
you start having kids you go to these
birthday parties and then you're back
into you're outside of your bubble and
now you're in like random distribution
of people and every time I'm like
where's the where's the entrepreneur in
the room and it was on the street I
gotta leave like you have to be around
them program has that great line where
he's like ambitious people are star
to be around other ambitious people if
you put them together they bloom like
dying plants with water which is exactly
what you're doing with Hampton the funny
thing is like oh thanks for doing this
like no no thank you for making your
[__] podcast I sit every day I get
messages like thank you for doing I was
like dude if you didn't listen like I
get to read books for a living I need to
be thinking you so that's the power
podcast so the answer questions like I'm
gonna vertically integrate
um what's that mean
by next year at this time
um like you're not gonna No One's Gonna
Be able to buy an adult Founders right
um so and this is the the crazy thing
about having a podcast so like you have
all you hit on it you're like uh super
successful people read all the time
um they also listen to business podcasts
all the time and you're able to build
relationships with them we're like uh I
just met like we said well when I talked
to Chris and Andrew I was like you guys
can advertise for as long as you want
but eventually like what you I think
ideally is like find a business you guys
buy businesses for a living you hire
managers for a living like
will partner up on distribution as
opposed to like just doing an ad uh you
have people like Patrick Ashanti from
invest like the best like literally
saying hey uh whether we have to buy a
company we scale it or we incubate a
company like basically he's like we need
to found we need to find Founders
version of tigas right and what does
that mean
this is something that I think is public
now so I don't think I'll get in trouble
for saying this I've heard about this
you want I can say it so you can you
don't get in trouble if you want so this
is just rumors so here let me tell you
the rumors that I heard so there's this
company and you could let me know so
this way you won't get in trouble for
revealing anything tigas is a company
where I think what they do is if you
wanted to talk to an expert you pay them
money and they connect you with an
expert but they record all the
conversations and transcribe them and so
instead of paying money to talk to an
expert you could just read the
transcriptions they had with any other
the other experts whatever
I heard that they advertised on Patrick
o'shaughnessy's Podcast and he saw how
good it was going and he goes screw this
I want some type of equity and I'll
invest a little bit but I want to add a
sweetheart deal and it was a sweetheart
deal and he continued sending them tons
of customers to the point where his
Equity hold holding in the company has
been were is worth tens of millions of
dollars is that roughly accurate so I I
don't know the prices I know he he says
this publicly he put 20 million into his
company he's got a giant fund too
um my point is like I don't know the
valuations I I'm sure if I asked Patrick
he would tell me but you know it's none
of my business
um my point is that like okay Michael
elnick who's the co-founder of tegus the
CEO and a [__] Savage like he is he
is like the guys we study right I was we
we talked I was talking to one more time
and um he was just telling me like oh
like what do you do like decompress like
you're in a [__] like he's building an
incredibly valuable company he's got a
like and he's completely dedicated to it
and him and his brother both ran track
at Brown so like they blow off stress by
like running like Phil Knight did in
Nike and then you ask him he's like oh
so like how much do you work he's like
oh no I take time off like I think
Saturday mornings off
that's it oh Saturday so he's on it I
love his intensity but he said he's just
like
one act one podcast they only advertised
they had their first two customers from
like you know Word of Mouth at their
network but you know the first probably
50 to 60 million dollars of Revenue
whatever it is like Patrick's podcast
because of who's in his audience helped
them scale and as a result like then
there's just a release there's a million
things you could do so in Patrick's face
he's running fun like you can do Equity
um I'm not an investor so you said the
other day when you were talking to um
Kimberly you were interviewing like you
don't like investing in people's
companies like you want to like build
your own ship yeah investing doesn't
entirely give me a dopamine rush like I
I'm I'm in the game for adventure and
that and I'm searching like uh like a
little bit of a rush and yeah I find it
to be very it's so boring you give
someone money and you don't hear from
them for six years I'm the same way I'm
like I'm not interested I get so much
deal flow like hey do you want an angel
best I'm like no like why I would just
like do my own [__] and people say I'm
stupid I'm doing that and they have to
understand it's like I'm not also
running my life to maximize for most
dollars mate like that doesn't make any
like it we talked about learning is not
just memorizing information it's
changing Behavior how many [__] times
you get to these super rich people that
do things they don't like for money and
then get money and they wonder why
they're not happy anymore all that
matters is how you spend your time
what's going to be your tigas though
what's going to be your product I don't
know what that see that's the thing is
like I was having conversation with two
Founders about this last night the good
thing is is like we have some ideas uh
obviously like we'll share that when
time comes but like I have all these
really smart successful people that like
the podcast that want to help you know
like Andrew and Chris are tiny I just
met with their eir I think they have
more than one but I just had a
conversation with their uh eir
um uh Patrick's trying to help me the
guy that connected me with Sam Zell he's
got like 20 billion dollars of assets
under management he's just like well we
can [__] buy company we can do
whatever you want you know he's also has
the best of some companies to scale up
I'm guessing so he understands power and
he just likes the product so the point
being is like that's where I'm going but
I'm not doing it for money I'm doing it
because I'm completely obsessed with
podcasting I think it's a miracle like
when I say I start talking [__] about
podcasts I'm like podcasting's [__]
uh it's to me it's like the printing
press for the spoken word it's like as
big a revolution as gutenberg's [__]
printing press and it's just like it's
on-demand audio that you can educate
yourself anytime you want all over the
world that's [__] crazy they didn't
exist when you and I were kids it didn't
exist I had to [__] I I remember like
being obsessed with talk radio and just
having to listen to whatever was on the
three or four dials at the time it was
on and then they go from that to like
streaming it in the browser I remember
when that happened I was a [__] grown
man I was like oh this is amazing and
then when my friend Eric's like oh no
you can listen to Joe's podcast
anytime you want like what the [__] did
you just say what the [__] did you just
say that's crazy and then think about
that like if somebody like this is um a
young kid so me and you both know
Michael secant who's Michael from our
future oh oh our future yeah dude he's
in my phone as Michael future and I
never referred to him as seeking his
last name never I was like I don't know
I don't think I'm pronouncing it
correctly
dude he's at my house he's at my house
like twice a week and I just call him
Michael future
I love how arrogant dude I had a guy at
my wedding and I didn't even I barely
even knew how to say this I didn't even
know his last name I just I just called
him cieva Russia I love Michael's
confidence and my point being is like
imagine being you know 20 20 because he
he would call DM both me and you and
yeah he he's really good at it he sent
me a DM he's like hey I love your
podcast it took an idea that I got for
your podcast made a video about it and
it got 10 million views can we talk I go
you did what what the [__] yeah it's an
impossible message not to dude I always
tell him he's at his house all the time
and like I'm not old I'm 33 but he he's
23 I mean he whatever he's first yeah
young and he'll come over and me and
Sarah will be like Michael just tell me
what's what are the young kids doing
nowadays and he'll literally just sit
there for two hours and just tell Sarah
and I like all these phrases and words
and I'm just I'll just listen I don't
even say a thing I just say just talk
just tell me like what's up with young
people and he's like well just tell me
and and I'll ask him about his dating if
you just talk and so I always tried it
this sounds always weird whenever it
says I always try to surround myself
with young like younger people and I'm
like just tell me I just want to listen
just tell me what's going on and he
always does this to me he's like you you
treated at one time he says I'm like oh
what are you gonna be doing in 10 years
I'm gonna be landing my helicopter on
your lawn or something but like I love
his confidence because like you one time
he said he goes got some really bad news
today just got back from the
chiropractor they said that the chip on
my shoulder is permanent
he actually gave me a really good book
recommendation she texted me yesterday
that I never had found it's like all
these like um
the ones that um I'm obsessed with the
history of the American West and like
yeah all that personality type that's
like oh no [__] the East Coast I'm gonna
go across and do this crazy
by uh Philip anschwitz or Antoine the
guy who owns um
the biggest ticketing company in the
world or something it's called like a w
e whatever it is it's like yeah one that
every everyone knows I think they own
Ticketmaster I think something like that
whatever the Lakers and the Coachella he
says I don't know if that's true but
yeah yeah I'll wear the West Begins yeah
and they own
um uh Coachella anyway this guy Philip a
lot of people don't know this it only
has 10 reviews on Amazon
Amazon this 80 year old 20 billion
dollar guy he has a book about the West
yeah and I already ordered it the the
reason I brought up Michael though is
because one I think it's smart to be
like I think we have a an epidemic of
people that don't believe themselves
people think we have an epidemic
arrogance I believe they complete
opposites like there's so many more
people that can create businesses
because like the best description of a
what a business is came from Richard
Branson I've ever heard came from
Richard Branson he goes a business is
just an idea that makes somebody else's
life better and if you look at it from
there like there's Limitless opportunity
and so to have the belief that you can
do that it's something that pops up
these books all the time is that belief
comes before a building but Society
wants you to show me that you're you
should like show prove that you should
have your confidence deserved it's like
no no you don't actually understand it's
like they the belief comes before then
that's why a lot of people
were like amongst my entrepreneurial
friends they watched the Billy McFarland
fire Festival documentary and they were
like yeah he did the wrong things
but it almost worked and the reason why
like a lot of my entrepreneurial friends
were like were like oh forgiving of him
was it's like yeah but I've been there
I've faked it until I made it type of
vibe and like because I remember I did
this for my conferences too I would kind
of FIB I would tell these 15 speakers
individually the other 14 had already
confirmed which they hadn't and luckily
I got them all to confirm and it worked
out so it wasn't and it didn't end up
being a lie but there's like so many
examples where I promised something that
wasn't real where I'm like oh [__] I got
I hope I can deliver on these things you
know yeah that happens a lot though the
point I was making with Michael though
is imagine being his age right and being
able to listen to every single episode
of my first million every single episode
of Founders or what are how how to take
over the world we got to get Ben a shot
out because [__] I think what he's
doing is incredible and like perfect
example is like dude you should just
make as many episodes possible because
like you have missed you have Sam par
saying your [__] is really good right
which is [__] incredible and you have
Mr Beast literally the biggest Creator
on the [__] internet saying to only
listen to One podcast so I hope that
like lights up a fire under Ben as well
but like just the ability like I would
kill I would have [__] killed for
that's why I think podcasting a miracle
I don't want to do anything else let's
say I never launch any businesses to
answer your 10-year plan which I I I
don't see how it's even possible because
there's a ton of entrepreneurs I know
that like want to partner on these
things
um but even if I just made podcasts and
I just continue to grow the audience and
I just made money on ad Revenue like
whatever I [__]
that's that's plenty fine for me that's
the way I like to live my life do you
ever read uh do you ever heard of Chuck
eager uh Chuck is that the guy who broke
the uh zombies so the [__] crazy
thing is the miracle uh books is like
you never know like where you're gonna
read some random sentence that you've
never everyone loves that guy's book all
business people love his book so I
didn't know who the [__] he was I kept
noticing this this old guy on Twitter in
a in a pilot suit talking hella [__]
like unfiltered and I [__] love these
people that like really talk who they
are they're authentic and I read his
book it turns out he [__] it sold
like five million copies the first year
came out in the 80s like it's one of the
most successful autobiographies of all
time well he was famous back then when
he did that he I think he broke the
sound barrier is that right so he broke
two or something he was the first pilot
to break the sound barrier and I think
he was the first pilot to become Ace in
a day uh in World War II he's like I
love killing Nazis he says he's like one
of my favorite things to do is kill
Nazis and so yeah he there's a great
line in his book where he he's like from
this like this is what I also love it's
like great can come from anywhere he
lived in like this rural um what's that
area in West Virginia it's like
Appalachian where there's like yeah yeah
so he lived in like the Appalachians
completely like isolated right and so he
describes the way he describes this book
about killing all these Nazis he shot
down fight to become an ace in a day at
the shoot down five enemy planes and he
goes the Nazis came up uh into the skies
and they met a goddamn West Virginia
Buzz saw that's the way he described
himself but he gave me a another
blueprint
um let me see if I can get the quote
exactly right this is the magic of
having read wise too because I can just
think of something and pull it up
immediately it's like a giant search
engine for everything I've read
um and he gave me this idea where it's
like it's how you and I should avoid
what you just described you get around
all these rich guys they never It's
never enough they don't seem to be
enjoying life which is what's the point
of being rich at that point
um they
it seems to be surprising to them that
they're not during life because they
don't actually like what they do day to
day but they make a ton of money so why
the [__] how the [__] could you take 130
of your life is going to be spent
working right you you hate what you do
you think how is it possible do you
think you're gonna get your end of your
life like you're like it's impossible
and so he says he goes I wasn't a deep
sophisticated person but I live by a
basic principle I did only what I enjoy
and here's the part it's I wouldn't let
anyone derail Me by Promises of power or
money into doing things that weren't
interesting to me and so it took me
years isn't that funny how that's like
business people say it Pilots say it it
doesn't matter like people a lot of
people who I talk to they they ask me
what my pot is if it's all about
business I'm like not really because
like I don't give a [__] if you're an
artist as long as you're like kicking
ass and you've like defined what success
is and you've achieved it I think that's
I think that's dope it's all the same
personality type just applied to
different things like I could show you
this I don't know if you've seen the
camera but like this is one of my
favorite dudes he's my [__] his
name's Ernest Shackleton I love reading
about polar explorers I like reading
about athletes that's the best book I've
read in probably three years endurance
yeah yeah it's excellent I'm gonna make
a shirt and I might sell it but I'll
just make it for myself with that
[__] picture where he's just like
covered in snow and looking like [__]
and I love the fact that he came up with
his own Motto by endurance we conquer
he's like we're just gonna win because
we're never gonna quit and I think that
could be applied to everything that you
[__] do assuming that you like to do
it but um yeah I think Truckee is a
smart word like so many people buying to
this this I feel Prestige is a myth
right where they're like I'm gonna go do
this I'm gonna do activity X because
it'll give me Prestige and what
prestigious is you think other people
are thinking about you and no one is
thinking about you you like humans are
self-absorbed that is our human nature
so like think about the person you I
listened to Ariel hawani uh interview
you're about it
you're a big fan of his how much of your
life is spent thinking about you're a
huge fan you buy all [__] you listen to
stuff
lesson two tenths of one million percent
of your life right I wish people
understood how few people are thinking
about them and therefore you wouldn't
Chase prestigious Prestige doesn't act
all that matters is like the people
around you do they do they think you're
a good person do they approve of what
you're doing and then your work all that
really matters is like your own opinion
right that Ben texted me the other day
about an idea for his podcast and I was
like dude because he's like he added
music Bad you care if I say this
okay so Ben added music he's like what
do you think of it and I was like I
don't love it and I don't hate it I
don't care about it at all I thought
your episode was fantastic it was
excellent I shared it with friends but I
was like he's like well the the reviews
are mixed so you go I saw that I went to
the tweets it's like some people like
this is great some people like this is
bad exactly
[__] exactly all that matters is what
you like if you like the music and they
don't then let them go find another
[__] podcast listen to dude his music
though on that first on his uh on how to
take over the world that's the best
intro song yeah
that that intro song has helped make uh
make his podcast popular the UFC like
that going back to the UFC thing that
that connected us too like go what like
I know you have but like everybody out
there needs to go talk about manifest
Cowboy Conor McGregor is it he is
literally in the documentary the fact
that he was had somebody film him when
he was flat broke living in his mom's he
owed money to every single [__]
agency in Ireland and he's like I'm
gonna be the [__] world champion one
day he's like literally manifesting this
[__] remember when he got the double
belts and he's like he Joe's
interviewing him he's like I saw this in
my mind he goes oh look at that he's
like I dream he's like I literally saw
it and I [__] made it real yeah
that's why people like him that
documentary is [__] incredible it's
because he called his shot it's like
this he just ruins it by do it he ruins
it by doing all the other dumb stuff
though but it certainly he's he's he
he's a he's I have a love-hate
relationship with them where it's like
you've got all this amazing stuff I
admire you so much and I also can't
stand some of this other Behavior you
know what I mean I think that's where
your wisdom is he's like okay I I stole
my company like I'm Rich As [__] uh
you're still like you have a massive
Advantage like uh you can launch
businesses do work on whatever you work
on but you're realizing this like but I
also like take care of my health I want
to spend time with my wife I want to
have a family I want to like be able to
like have freedom I've heard you
describe like what's important to you
and this is like yeah that's that's how
I feel too because like it's my issue is
like I'm not impressed by somebody
successful for a year five years ten
years it's like I like the people that
[__] never [__] it up and
um there's a great line of Charlie
Munger said he's like it's not getting
rich that you have to worry about it's
staying sane he's like it's not part and
this isn't a book it's not normal to
human nature to have unlimited resources
or be so much Rich richer and then not
[__] it up through he he says uh through
ladies leverage and liquor is usually
how rich men go broke
it's in this book he didn't say it in
person but um the point being is like I
think there's a sense of wisdom there
where it's like okay I already have this
how do I keep building on it people like
Connor and and Kanye West is in this
example too it's like they're gifted at
a young age and then they're they're
Superstar success is so disorienting
that like again it's not getting rich
you have to worry about it's staying
sane they weren't able to stay sane I
want to stay sane dude I want to get to
them in my life when I'm I try to make
decisions like when I'm 80 years old it
might like I knew for a fact uh part of
the reason I I felt comfortable like
jump all in on the podcast even though I
didn't know if I was gonna make a
success or not was that when Jeff Bezos
is like well
I was making a ton of money as this
hedge fund I was 30 years old I had an
apartment on the upper west side I'm
best friends with a billionaire who's
like mentoring me like he's already set
for life right
but he's like I knew if I quit now and
forego my quarterly bonus and move
across the country Seattle and try to
sell books on the internet he's just
like
I feel that the internet is a
life-changing technology and I want to
play a role in that technology and the
30 year old self you can confuse
yourself and think oh it's our c as
prestigious as working in a hedge fund
it I'm gonna miss out on you know a
couple million dollar bonus whatever it
is he's like your 85 year old self is
gonna be like you had a shot to play a
little on internet and you didn't do it
that's how I feel about podcasting it's
just like I believe it's a miracle I
want to play a role and therefore like I
want to get to my life I know 80 year
old's like damn David I'm glad you
[__] risked it
I'm happy you came on here you're um
you're very fascinating to me I've
listened to dozens of your episodes
um I'm very eager to see what you become
I think it's cool I didn't know that
you're doing it for six years I know
that I've listened to like
episode like number 10 as well as like
300 so I guess I should have done the
math but like congratulations on your
success it seems like you're kicking ass
it seems like you're in the groove and
like it's really cool to see someone
like it's really fun to see someone
um like right when it's happening and
that's like kind of the cool thing about
podcasting and like Twitter and all this
stuff is like you can catch stuff in the
middle not before and not after but as
it's happening that's where you are
right now and I appreciate you doing
this where um what do you what do you
promote just Founders I call it Founders
pod it's a Founders podcast Founders
Twitter your Founders uh just always
tweeting good [__]
um I want to say thank you for having me
on like seriously I love your [__]
podcast I would just say that um one
thing that podcasters uh like
it's obvious who has the magic and I've
been telling people way before I ever
[__] message you I was like you need
to watch what Sam and Sean are doing
it's clear they have the magic they have
insane chemistry I remember listening to
you guys when you're like oh I'm only
getting 60 000 downloads an episode
which is still super impressive and now
you guys are [__] blue right past
that
um it's extremely obvious that you guys
are really good at it I hope you like do
a ton of it I swear and I know you might
not be interested in this but like
there's a there's a massive hole in
podcasting for like the Pat McAfee
version of business podcast I agree
and I think you and Sean you and Sean
like like dude there is going to be a
business podcast where you have Pat
McAfee gets paid like 30 million a year
by whatever his presenting sponsor is
whatever like I forgot what it is
um Dan Le batard got that 50 million
contract from like DraftKings you see
Spotify gave uh Alex Cooper 20 million a
year the the reported number for Joe
Rogan is way bigger than it's reported
but my point being is like there's a gap
in the [__]
business podcast space which I think you
and Sean have the best way to like if
you did it every day just like you did
like your hour show is a perfect length
the research the it feels like you're
hanging out with your smart friends and
you guys are brainstorming together
there's nothing else that's like what
you guys are [__] doing hey Spotify
if you're listening I'm I'm easy to
contact you you just DM me on Twitter
I appreciate you inviting me on those
[__] super cool with you I appreciate
you doing this and uh
yeah it means a lot and uh yeah it was
awesome that's the pod that's the pod
foreign
[Music]